so I've seen the latest episode yep
black maritime again folks and I'm now
seeing the episode smithereens and I
have I saw it about I don't know what
time am i recording this oh geez about
eight hours ago and I'm still not
entirely sure how I feel about it I
don't mean that in a bad way I know it's
good I'm just trying to figure out how
much I personally like it um I think I'm
for myself I probably put it in about
the middle which is which is actually
not the condemnation it might be under
other circumstances normally when you
call something middling that's the
equivalent of me but when the bar is as
high as black Mara tends to set it and
I'll clarify that I actually only think
there's one episode of Blackmer that I
don't think is actually good and only
one more after that that I think is
interesting but has some serious
problems and everything else it's it's
all good it's just a question of how I
personally prefer it so what I say in
the middle that's not the condemnation
it sounds like but it is it is
interesting and not on this is one of
the those that is actually set in the
modern day with modern actually
technically set in the past because it's
dated 2018 I don't remember any other
black mayor episode being dated
specifically like that so that was
interesting so this one falls into the
category of things like say shut up and
dance or the national anthem in that
nothing about the technology is more
advanced than what we have today
some of it is invented insofar as there
are pieces of technology that exist that
are that obviously have real
equivalents but are named something else
so like there's a there's a ride-sharing
app but they don't call it Ober there's
you know some sort of social media thing
that's called persona you know there's
and there's things like that but like
it's all very clearly analogues for
technology that exists so this is a
modern a story about one man and the
state that he is currently in and the
the degrees he decides to take things to
try and you know what I can't even
really say what it is he's doing without
getting into what I would consider to be
spoilers so I just need to get into it
and maybe that's part of why I find this
kind of meddling I'm having a hard time
landing firmly on the point it's making
um I have some ideas and this isn't even
me necessarily it's making its point
badly but just I'm having to sort
through a lot this is the kind of
episode that when I either end up
rewatching it or I think about it again
in a few days I'm either going to
severely upgraders have really downgrade
my assessment depending on on once I
actually get things fully sorted but
this primarily deals with a character
played by Andrew Scott at this point I
think best known in most circles for
play Moriarty in the BBC Sherlock that
had been added Cumberbatch in it and he
is he's really good for a part like this
I mean part of what made him a good
Moriarty is he is there's something
about him that is inherently a little
bit disconcerting and even when I've
seen him in stuff where he's playing a
protagonist to character he's still kind
of disgusted somewhat was a denial he
was it was decent movie but you know
he's there's still something a little
unsettling about him and this plays very
well into that plus the man can rant
he's very good at ranting so he there
was plenty of moments for him to get
this so basically he kidnaps well what
he believes to
an employee of a tech company called
smithereen and he you know holds him at
gunpoint
it finds out he's managed to bag just an
intern but he's got somebody so he is
trying to use that and threatening him
with a gun to be able to talk on the
phone with the guy who created
smithereen and is the owner of it so
it's I mean it's like kidnapping
somebody from Amazon and trying to talk
to Jeff Bezos I mean that's basically
what he's doing
so there's a the degree to which this
works a lot of the centers on the
performance Andrew Scott is terrific
he's really good it's a powerful
performance and there's something that
he does that I related to a lot cuz that
like my ability to relate to this
character was it wasn't great but there
was something that he is like oh crap I
do that that is very me it was it was
kind of cool to see because I can't
think I've thought my head of too many
other times I've seen it depicted well
which is that when when things don't go
the way he intended or planned he gets
really aggravated and like when he finds
out he he got an intern you know just a
sort of you know in swearing and cursing
and ah and then 10 then gets that takes
a breath okay so here's what we're gonna
do and like I'm watching they like crap
that's me because when something
unexpected happens I do kind of have a
like oh okay so here's how we're gonna
deal with this now
and then the knit then the next thing
that is supposed to repair the first
thing that didn't work that doesn't work
and the cycle repeats so I did feel for
him on that uh-huh that that was that
was really well captured and
um the other performances are pretty
good too
the guy plays the intern is good the the
various police characters who get
involved for good Topher Grace plays the
the the tech CEO and he's pretty good
too he he also finds an interesting
balance in terms of very much feeling
like a rich tech kind of a little bit of
a douchebag not like a raging douchebag
was a little bit of a douche and but
also like having moments where he's you
know the guys trying he is trying to be
decent he is trying to help but at the
same time like he's obviously got an ego
that does start getting in the way so
like towards the tail end when the two
of them are actually on the phone and
talking together he actually does kind
of connect a little bit with what you
know the guy who's holding somebody
hostage is saying but then he kind of
twists it around and makes it about him
and it's like ah dude like you were
there and then you just kept going and
so again pretty well captured All Things
Considered I think the reason I'm not
entirely sure how I feel about this is
because ultimately if it's it's very
true to I would say actually like first
season maybe first two seasons of black
mirror in that what solidifies the the
point of it kind of comes in over the
end credits which like I think honestly
was the case with the previous episode
striking vipers it was definitely the
case with national anthem those are the
ones off the top of my head but I know
that there were others beside that and I
feel like that's trying to be the case
here but I don't know just something
about what gets revealed it doesn't feel
overly telling I guess so how I
interpreted this whole thing was
the reason that this guy is doing all of
this is just to know that he was hurt
because he was involved in an accident
that he feels responsible for because he
was looking at his phone at this app at
smithereen when he got into a crash that
ultimately resulted in the death of his
fiancee and he hasn't told anyone that
so there's sort of this need to say it
but also like I need to know he's being
hurt and to be heard by somebody who
matters as opposed to just you know
throwing it up on his social media for
you know the standard condolences he'd
get so at the end when you know after
he's been shot and we're just getting
glimpses of people like ordinary people
glancing at their phone presumably at
this app that's alerting them just sort
of looking anger yeah and then moving on
with their lives seems to be leaning
towards a point of you know that this is
fleeting the world that we built around
this technology nothing sticks nothing
is lasting but I guess I feel slightly
at odd because nothing about what the
guy was doing was trying to be noticed
by the masses at least didn't feel like
it was so either I'm misinterpreting
what sort of those closing moments are
meant to be conveying or I'm
misinterpreting the character and why
he's doing what he's doing because if
I'm right about both they don't fully
click they don't properly complement
each other oh one thing that did get me
and I actually kind of choked up was
with the with the mother that
he actually hooks up with from the grief
group whose daughter committed suicide
and she's been trying to guess the
password for her persona account to try
and get access to the inbox and have
some indication some clue as to why her
daughter's dead and you know she's the
the company won't give her the password
so she's been guessing she only gets
three times a day and then the and then
it locks down for 24 hours then she has
to try and guess again the next day who
knows how long she's been at this and I
like that and discuss character has you
know I think as he realizes he's gonna
die which honestly may have been his
time from the get-go that he because
he's got this guy on the phone this
massive important XE he goes hey do you
know the guy who owns persona and we
don't see the whole conversation but he
basically asked him for a favor for this
woman and neuronal you I like that but I
really like that she gets the password
and it just looks like a string of
letters and numbers it looks like the
sort of thing like when you just invent
randomness you know to create the
strongest password and but then as she
enters it in and she looks at this
picture of this framed picture that was
in her daughter's dorm room of the two
of them together the password is a is a
number from off the side of the boat in
the background of this picture and there
was something really touching about that
moment freaking but there was something
very sweet and I got a little choked up
at that you know the sort of because you
know she'd been all the passwords she'd
been guessing were you know things that
connected two of them and none of them
were working
I know I'm gonna snap soon
I should have muted that but it's it's
just really sweet to us no no it was
still a connection and of course we
never see the results of that inbox just
like there's a fair amount we don't see
at the very end but a lot that's implied
and I may have to rewatch this if I was
smarter I'd watch it again before I put
this review up but I've got too much
other stuff did too so I'll probably not
but smithereens it was good but I feel
like either it's missing a little
something I think kind of akin to the
Waldo moment because I've said before
that the Waldo moment is dealing in
really interesting elements that don't
fully complement each other and I feel
like it needed like another draft or
something to fully coalesce and either
this is a case like that or there's just
something I missed
there's just something I'm not getting
about what it's doing and what it's
trying to say and I'm totally open to
that possibility that I just didn't get
something but the essential performance
is phenomenal it's emotional and it's
engaging and it's witty well done and it
is it's a good piece I just I feel like
I'm missing something and the question
is is it there and I missed it or is it
actually missing I don't know
smithereens what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments
let's talk about a whole bunch of stuff
to do because there's buttons and links
and patreon you can support this channel
help make it better and there's merch
and there's my socials and
blah blah blah blah blah it's all down
in the description so give it a look
click the links they'll take you places
or don't you don't have to it's at the
end of the day you are the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]